Bottle! Look at the  bottle! It cracked it!
Whats up guys we're back I'm Grant Thompson ' The King Of Random' And I'm Lance Stewart.
And today we are playing with science!
What are we doing today Lance?
I have no idea somethings going to explode, apparently.
He has no idea, but you guys remember this thing we did a experiment a little while ago
where you asked us to make carbonated drinks with dry ice
and we did it and we used apple juice to turn it into that sparkling cider.
which is amazing we kept the bottle for this experiment today.
So here's how it's going to work, Lance my friend is going to take some water
We're going to put a little bit of water of each of these bottles here
We're also using this Nantucket Nectars from his friend Aiden
Who happily donated to the cause today
And we're just going to stick these things in the microwave for about 2 minutes
what that's going to do is let the water heat up until its boiling
We are going for Lance's we're going to create steam
the steam is going to fill the bottles
we're going to take it out the microwave
turn upside down and stick it into this
bowl of water right here just to see
what happens let's check it out cool all
right Lance this is the part where we
put our gloves on for safety glasses on
for safety so the reason we're using two
different bottles is because of the
shape and size of that obviously this is
a lot bigger the necks are about the
same but we're going to see how they
react differently with the steam
starting off would be N and then
whatever juice this is we're just going
to pour a little bit of water in there
it doesn't take much because when water
turns to steam it increases in volume
dramatically now we're going to do is
take this bottle we're going to stick it
in the microwave for two minutes we're
going to vaporize most of that water so
we do that next do it two minutes please
and you can just set the bottle on its
side our microwave already had like a
little bit of destruction a little bit
of a mess unlike previous experiment put
it in there for two minutes and it put a
little ice in this bowl just to cool it
down a little bit because the colder we
can get the water the faster the
reaction is going to take place unless
is wondering what kind of reaction are
we talking about no idea what is going
to happen guess that's what we got to
see going explode in my face probably
oh yeah I think that's ready so guys our
time is up what Lance is going to do now
is open the microwave he's going to grab
the bottle bring it over here pour out
any excess water so the bottle is
completely empty then dunk it down below
the water line so it's underneath the
ice hold it very firmly in place and
we're going to wait all right let's try
it out there you go perfect ready hold
it a little bit
whoa whoa it sucked all of it up that
was pretty cool that was quick
as the steam condensed the water went up
to fill the bottle I think we can make
it a little more dramatic so there's a
couple things we can do differently
let's do the same thing again but this
time we're not going to press it down to
the bottom because when you have it
against the bottom it's going to
restrict the flow yeah and second of all
I think it's gonna be a really good idea
to remove this label so we can exactly
see what's going it was literally just
like a complete vacuum homemade vacuum
cleaner
all right that should be enough time
let's go ahead and pull this thing out
so we're going for round two we've nuked
this bottle again it's full of steam
this time when we put the bottle down
into the water it's going to go just
below the surface it's not going to
touch the bottom just going to hold it
in place let's try it out go for it
hot hot stuff hold it at the top here
there you go oh whoa that's so hot but
that is sick it takes a couple of
seconds but it just it completely sucks
it all off that's very cool I need to
see how like filled the entire bottle
yeah it goes all the way to the edge so
that's the power of like how you can use
steam to create a vacuum so now that we
know the works of this bottle what do
you think would happen if we try it with
this bottle we get it to fill entirely
any difference do you think it would
fill entirely or do you think it will
fill like most of the way but not all
the way Dingle not fill at all this is
the tenth how much water we put in there
as well to begin with that's a good
question what if we only put a tiny bit
of water in there what's your prediction
if we want to put that much water in
there I still think it's gonna fill
entirely let's give it a try
okay so guys that last one was kind of
cool right I mean yeah you put the
bottle in a syllabic water nothing super
dramatic lapses over here is like the
big deal like what are we doing is this
going to be a dramatic I don't know I
guess we're going to find out I'm
getting a hint that it might say perfect
alright here we go a moment of truth is
hot stuff okay we go three two one
oh we were going to sucked up the ice
we've had a couple ice cubes in there as
well that was quick
how fast was that that was really quick
that's a little bit more what I was
expecting guys so it seems like the
longer you make these things the harder
it gets the quicker the reaction takes
place I mean look at that that jar went
from zero to full in point point zero
three six second we spin it we can get a
little corn a Doyle thing oh that's dope
stuff that's pretty sweet huh oh it was
that a little bit more way better
laughter worthy yeah a couple years ago
I had a friend called Darren Dyke come
over with a slow-motion camera we tried
this with one of these like gallon apple
juice containers we actually filmed it
in 4,500 frames per seconds we could see
what's happening and even at that frame
rate it happened so quickly we couldn't
see the transition point between when
water started and when it slows the
whole dark that is insane it literally
like what's happening is the steam in
here is contracting so fast that it's
sucking up the water which cools down
more steam it's like this
self-perpetuating cycle it's almost like
an explosive reaction so let's throw
this in microwave one more time for mr.
Lapp Stuart I want to give you this
experience probably I feel he's gonna
suck it like it looked like it sucked
your hand all the way in yeah it was
like you got to do it you gotta hang on
to it tight cousins left yeah thanks for
right so the key it looks like it's to
put it in the microwave a little bit
longer we're doing this one for four
minutes to get that water superheated
you know this stuff getting ready when
the bottle starts jumping in the
microwave like the water starts
exploding
yeah you can hear it rolling in there
very very dangerous situation it's a
very very good sign because that's
exactly what we're looking for I add
boiling you can see it popping off yeah
steam three two one let's do it
okay
the whole thing's heard like it pull at
news you see you shot backwards bull
jumped over it's a good thing I didn't
step back or else I wouldn't be able to
go inside in public with any kind of
dignity because oh my gosh I was like
all over waist level there it's dripping
everywhere I gotta clean this all the
neighbors down below or like what the
heck it's raining we're going to do one
more experiment of this with a slo-mo
for you guys let's see how this look
here we go oh look at the bottle look at
the bottle look at the bottle exactly
well I wasn't strong enough to hold it
and they just like slammed it down on
the counter and busted okay well we're
going to call that good because I'm not
doing that again yeah the whole bottle
is crap look at that Wow okay you could
just see the steam rising out wow I was
not strong enough to hold that it
literally ripped the bottle right out of
my hand slammed it into the countertop
and busted it that's been sane so
there's one of those experiments you try
at home no this is one of those
experiments you try Lance's home okay
well guys big thanks to Lance Stewart
for letting us crash this place today
and try a little mad science out here on
Vine Street and you can go check out on
the links down in the description I'll
put a link he does daily vlogs and he's
always getting up to some pretty crazy
stuff what do you want these guys to
know about you and so for example me and
grant has filled our bodies with gasses
and see how they reacted our body and
the one made my voice like Cooper crazy
it was almost like demonic sounding oh
yeah it's can go check the link in the
description go check out lamp store he's
got good times for you and thanks again
for joining us for this experiment guys
we'll be looking for you in the next one
doc you then pouring water looks just
science when you're wearing gloves and safety glasses right